就是我发现我老公从去年5月份开始就频繁的和他的一个女同事聊天，
聊天记录也没有什么特别露骨的暧昧的消息，
但是就会分享他，
他一起打游戏，
分享游戏啊日常啊，
带娃啊之类的，
然后直到上个月那个女同事给我老公寄了一个可以私现在手机上的那种卡包，
然后我在心里面就开始很不舒服，
然后我就跟他讲，
我说要有边界感，
因为对方也是已婚已育，
我说你也是已婚已育，
交流点这个界限，
然后我我答应我不再跟他主动发消息，
但是直到前两天我看到他在我旁边给那个女同事就是拍游戏的照片，
然后实在忍不住没跟他吵架了，
然后他觉得他没有错，
反而被我动手了，
他说我没事找事，
然就把我推倒在地，
然后就是一一巴掌打了我的头，
然后当时就耳鸣了，
然后我当时是下定决心要跟他分手的，
但是后来也没有分成，
然后昨天我说我被你打的特别地方我有疼痛，
然后我要去医院检查，
然后他在陪我去医院的路上，
他竟然就是像开玩笑一样，
他就说等你伤好了我就拿。
然后他，
然后他边说边比划那个姿势，
边喊着那三个字，
然后我就感到特别恐怖，
因为这不是他第一次这样说我，
他之前没有讲过，
就是把我带到婚无人烟的地方，
用钥匙，
然后托我的眼睛，
然后我就感觉这个人很恐怖，
我就想我是不是应该跟他分手，
因为我觉得他到现在他都没有认识到他的错误，
一个是他觉得他跟女同事聊天是很正常，
再一个是他觉得他打我，
他觉得是跟我学了，
因为我承认我以前有吵架的时候，
我也有动手打他，
我不知道是不是在报复我还是怎么，
还是他确实心里有问题，
我跟你讲啊，
姐妹啊，
人是这样子的，
你要相信自己的第6感，
你你跟他在一起的时候，
你会不会害怕他，
会不会恐惧他，
会不会怕他来，
真的？
如果你会害怕，
会恐惧，
会怕他来真的，
这就是在救你的命，
你一定要去相信自己的第6感，
他吵架的时候，
我相信他真的会出这种事，
如果不吵架，
不会这好，
那就跑，
你没有办法拿自己的生命当赌注的，
明白吗？
姐妹，
从我这个角度来说的话，
我宁可错过一个男人，
我也不愿意自己放命，
我宁可错过一个可能是不错的男人，
但我不愿意拿我自己的命当成一个赌局，
不知道，
如果真的分手的话，
是这样，
那天吵架，
他自己手写了一个。
分手协议，
他说他净身出户，
然后每个月给小孩写两年，
这个奏效吗？
我告诉你啊，
协议这个事儿，
一定是你俩去了民政局民申写备案的那一份才奏效，
就是离婚协议之上，
我我如果再在跟他提，
他不会同意的，
就肯定回定，
还会到后面要打官司估计才可以，
但是我跟他协议话，
他肯定要我进行诉护，
现在孩子是多大5岁男孩女孩儿，
你说他对孩子怎么样啊，
对孩子很好，
挺好，
他自己是干什么工作的，
我跟他都是挺姐那的，
他平时跟别人沟通和交往的时候，
你有见识过他的温柔没有，
跟他同学朋友打游戏的时候会骂，
就是生气了后会骂人，
然后我就觉得也挺可怕的，
你爸爸妈妈是干啥的呀？
姑娘都退休了，
有退休金哈，
对，
你们两口子有多少财产呢？
一套房子，
一辆车，
还有一点存款，
那个存款我是存在了小孩的名下，
如果分割的话，
这个财产了也算夫妻共同财产吗？
还拿出来分割吗？
是有这种可能性的，
就是假设啊，
他也知道这个存款的存在，
你存在了孩子的名下，
他主张的说这个是实际上是我们夫妻两口子的资产，
如果存在孩子名下，
是有这种可能性的，
我如果不想分割的话，
是不是要跟他签协议之类的，
这个可以，
那既然是。
不签的话，
那也没有什么办法，
姑娘你记住啊，
在生死面前，
在生命面前，
其他的这些利益都可以让路，
如果你真的跟他在一起的时候，
感受到了他对你生命健康的这种威胁的话，
经济上的话，
反正就是该怎么样怎么样，
该怎么分怎么分都可以让步，
他教我有没有可能是那种他，
因为我之前被他动的时候，
他的一种报复感，
还是说他其实可以定义有可能就这个事情啊，
我们要自己也要调整自己，
一个女孩子，
我经常跟大家讲，
一个女孩子你千万别动不动就上手，
因为你力量上及身体结构上，
你不可能干得过一个男的，
你那么多就上手，
这事儿的话需要改，
嗯，
其实我想分手，
他有很多妇女在里面，
我还是想争夺一下财产，
再一个就是不给小孩子确实蛮好的，
然后他那个分资也都给我，
就这两点让我还是有点不知道该不该就就因为这两点，
所以我还在纠结，
如果没有这两点，
我肯定是肯定要跟他分手，
姐妹，
这个事情一定是回到你自己的感受上，
因为你自己这几十万个细胞是长在你身上的，
你的这个触感和这个第6感是长在你身上的，
还是回到你身上，
就是你跟他在一起的时候，
如果你能感受到生命和健康。
方的危险，
能感受到生命和健康的这种害怕和恐惧，
一定要逃离，
那如果我跟他那个协议分手，
如果他不同意的话，
我是要不要先搬出去住，
然后再起诉，
要要最好是跟爸爸妈妈住在一起，
让我妈下个月过来带小孩，
然后我们就谈这个事情，
谈不拢就搬出去啊，
我想问一下，
就是这个房子呢，
100万首付一共是145万，
首付100万是他妈妈出的，
然后后面那45万呢，
我用彩礼出的，
然后那个房子写的是共同共有，
那么在分哥的话，
那100万他分之工，
他没有欠条，
然后这个100万的房源会按照出租别例房房可签吗？
这个房子是登记在你们两个人的名下写的，
他那共同共有，
而是在你们领完结婚证之后才购买的，
这个房子是不是，
那么这个房子首先从定性上来说，
他会被定性为是夫妻的共同财产，
然后如果你想要这个房子的话，
得给他钱，
如果他想要这个房子的话，
得给你钱，
至于说你该给他多少钱，
会不会考虑到他妈妈出的多出了100晚会，
因为你们孩子也还很早，
你们结婚的时间长短现在是几年，
在你结婚的时间也不算太长，
在这种情况。
下啊，
还是会考虑到他妈妈出了100万这个因素在里面，
可能不见得是50%，
对50%这么比例去分，
有可能比如说他分的多一点，
55%，
60%都是有可能的，
那个权利是掌握在法官的手里的，
那这个法人的抚养权是不是基本上可以判定给我大概率一下吧，
因为第一这个孩子才两岁，
还很小，
第二是个女儿，
还有我老公的那个，
他有心脏病，
然后我有他的病例证明，
是不是印象没他的心脏病是会有什么继续血，
然后他有病假单在他里面去加了病，
放天在家，
在家他有病，
这个事儿会不会影响到孩子归谁，
主要取决于这个病会不会就是对他照顾孩子的能力有所下降，
他照顾孩子照顾的不好，
会不会影响到这个，
他医生前天说还有猝起的风险啊，
但然这个这个病例你该提交还是要提交的，
就刚才这个连麦的这个妹妹啊，
因为从你的那个描述当中，
我会有一种鸡皮疙瘩都起来的那种感觉，
我会有一种毛孔竖起来那种恐惧，
就你描述他说啊，
你好了之后，
我就拿那么你就这那的啊，
从你的描述当中我都能感受到那种恐惧。
我现在特别怕这样的人，
特别怕太细腻了被特别怕这样的人，
我一听到你说用你的生命去威胁你的时候，
去害让你害怕，
让你屈服的时候，
我第一反应就是说，
你要相信你自己的第6感，
相信你自己跟这个人在一起的时候，
会不会感受到那种恐惧，
害怕，
好吧。